we have a voicemail number that is two
one nine to david p here's a funny
voicemail we talked about you know these
shows these right-wing Christian shows
that sell bulk food and we now have a
voicemail suggesting hey with Trump
selection maybe we should be looking
into that bulk food hey David Rachel Pat
guys Louis if you happen to be listening
it to beyond from Dallas Texas I was
calling cuz i would like to order two
bushels of david pakman dehydrated but
to be delivered honor before january
twentieth 2017 yeah you can get back to
me at this number with regard to this
offer i look forward to hearing from you
guys keep doing what you're doing i'm so
excited to delegating more membership
okay uh we have no plan to start selling
the dehydrated mashed potatoes coffee is
coming soon but no dehydrated mashed
potatoes for the time being on the bonus
show today alaska airlines makes history
by flying a commercial flight using
renewable alternative jet fuel very
interesting we will also talk about the
reality that many of those currently in
college are pursuing careers where most
of the jobs will be obsolete because of
technology with inner soon after the
time that they graduate and we will also
talk about a potential Chelsea Clinton
congressional congressional run is this
a good idea what does this mean for
progressives what does this mean for the
Democratic Party establishment david
pakman.com slash membership that's the
one place to sign up for membership and
you can use coupon code i voted 17 for a
big big league forty percent discount
off of membership